okay let's open up the
subcommittees first up
ambulances so
um so Mark we we
have the uh these checks that were sent
out um need to say I was kind of shocked
to see a check that's
$5,000 uh the the first question I would
be posing on terms of this 5,000 deck um
it turns out that
some uh
some insurance companies and Anthem
might be one of them actually does pay
the balance
billing so in terms of the way you read
the statute the right now do you see
that is that is means any check that
insurance company sends to the customer
to the patient regardless of whether
it's balance billing or not is that what
you're looking
at because that was never the intent of
legislation was always it was in my mind
in my memory was always just what the
reimbursement uh for the
uh whether ambulances in network or not
and that the ambulance company uh excuse
me the insurance company would send the
ambulance company the check and if and
and obviously they were that my
understood was that they were sending
the check to the patient if the
ambulance company was out of
network okay so the question is if all
we did is
say assum assuming that it's
only the reimburse for the ambulance and
not the balance
billing okay because evidently some
insurance companies pay the balance
billing and some do
not and you point out MVP and by the way
MVP left the state like five years
ago right so if if the if the if the
issue if we were going to narrow down
the issue is it's only the only check
that that we're focusing in is we're not
focusing on the balance billing check
we're focusing on just the check the
insurance company is reimbursing the
patient
with then that would be a reasonable I
guess
compromise right the bill well at least
that's what we think it is but but I I
think
when
it's covering the charge of the
bill should come to
us right but we we know that when it
comes
to all other health insurance costs when
they send a check they're there to the
provider that's based on the contracted
price it's negot it's not the full
price so that to to keep it Apples to
Apples then as long as if we write the
legislation to say is what the
reimbursement but
not the balance billing no the balance
billing you still have to collect from
the
patient we want you to join the network
and evidently for Anthem there is a huge
chunk of there's 100 people 100
different ambulances that are in
network so that that's not a problem
they and they get a bigger check
than join because we don't them because
we
reimb service right I understand so so
basically what we're doing is we want to
raise everybody's premiums in the small
group
market so that that ambulances get to be
one thing that nobody else no other
healthc care provider gets no hospital
gets is the full
amount is that is that fair so if I
understand it ambulance billing is like
1% of their their total output
1% 35% sorry of their whole outlook so
us getting the full check to keep a
solvent isn't going to break
them I don't see that at all well I I
would have a problem with that no I'm
sorry that that that is throwing the
whole Managed Care the whole
reimbursement system in the trash can we
cannot do that or you can pay Paul
because what we need to make up in the
emergency service is going to go to your
taxpayer right community so so now
you're spreading that one person's bill
over the town right not just on that one
person but let's think about this for a
second what would then stop all the
other providers all the other healthc
care all the other hospitals and doctors
and all them to come in and say well gee
you gave it to the ambulances why can't
you give that to us too we don't want to
open
247 no matter what they are not they
have patients lined up they schedule
accordingly they don't wait for calls
they don't wait for patients
well emergency rooms
do emergency rooms do not wait for
patients there's LS out the door no no
there's plenty of plenty of emergency
rooms that are sitting there waiting for
people yes okay but that's the model I
mean again we're talking about the
business model okay and you're asking
for something as a special privilege to
say well ambulance compan so we can just
you know some of them are talents but
some of them are not some of them are
private businessmen okay not many well
anyway
okay the issue of saying is we're going
to the issue I always thought was the
reimbursement rate from the insurance
company for the ambulance so the n n in
network no well let me just say what way
I did understand that there was always
two different amounts that if you were
in network you got a bigger check if
you're out of
network okay do we agree on that and
that's fair okay that if you sign a
contract you're going to get
more right so that you're okay with that
right no you're not even okay with that
either so you're basically saying you
don't even want him to sign a contract
you saying they're gonna if I submit the
bill and I'm in network they're going to
pay me the whole bill nope they're not
right so it's they don't pay anybody the
whole bill they don't pay any other
profession nobody not even Pharmacy not
even doctors not even hospitals nobody
gets the full
pay nobody's like
us okay representative
collabor I
think the quibble here seems to be about
the legislation to write something that
has been taking place for a very long
time and that is that the fees for
served are not
sufficient we're assuming that this
status quo is the model you want to
continue and what these towns and
municipalities are trying to say and
I've been a part of their volunteer
Ambulance Service in the past
is that they won't stay solvent with
these fees for service the way they are
and they're begging for our support
that's what I'm trying to say somebody
is going to have to cover it at some
point and if the onus becomes these
municipalities the wait times are going
to be longer for and lives will be lost
volunteers will not step
up that's all I'm trying to say so it
doesn't bother you that
um private insurance insurance company
is only
20% the rest of it is
orisas small B large businesses Medicare
Medicaid and you doesn't bother you that
we can't force them to pay more you just
want to go after the small businessman
the small businesses you just think that
they're the ones what are you talking
small businesses okay what this this
legislation affects is only small
employers and individuals what ambulance
and the ambulance mandate okay we have
no legislative control I know we haven't
really talked about this over the years
you know usually the old days we used to
uh go go through this issue all the time
because we used to get a lot of health
insurance mandates we haven't gotten
them so much uh because of the
Affordable Care Act saying that if we
were to pass a new mandate the cost
would then have to be passed on uh to
the state okay so that's why we have not
had this conversation but if you were to
take all the people who are insured out
there okay you say 100% of the
population obviously there some are
uninsured so we're taking that off but
we have the number one employer based
health insurance plans are called
arises which is a created back uh Gerald
Ford was president and it's an
employer-based health insurance plan
otherwise it's known as
self-insured okay um and and the state
is in a Risa
plan some of our my coun is are Rises I
don't know you know but a lot of large
employers are Rises so this legislation
does not affect
them they're outside of this
legislation this legislation affects a
very Nar narrow
group and that is the small employer
50 or
less so the question is do you want to
make them pay the full amount while
everybody else will pay what they feel
like paying no I want the insurance
companies to do the right thing by
everybody this is I we we can't do
anything about that okay so I was just
saying is that if if we want to get to
the question is that yes it is true we
have this cost differ ual about which
which ambulance companies sign a
contract or don't sign a contract that
there are reimbursement levels different
if we want to write this legislation
which I always thought this is what the
issue was about okay so this is news to
me that I just decid you know asked this
question that they're now asking for the
balance billing payments if the
insurance company was generous enough to
pay that because not all all companies
not all companies pay the balance
billing okay so if the insurance company
is willing to pay the balance billing
should they also be sending that check
to the ambulance company or sending it
to the patient and have the patient send
it because the ambulance company made
the decision not to sign a
contract does that make
sense okay go ahead
guys
thanks for the opportunity to speak
Chris STW was from Hollis I'm a little
confused that now as far as I'm aware
this legislation only applies to direct
payments that are currently going to
patients doesn't include balance billing
doesn't include any of those other
things all we are asking to do is to
take the name of the patient off the
check and put the name of the ambulance
company that provided the service on the
check and mail it to them simple as that
and you understand that that does not
necessarily if the if the insurance
company were to reimburse the patient
for the balance
billing you're not asking for that
check no and what we're asking for is is
budget neutral because they're already
paying the amount I am I glad we got to
this agreement I'm glad you came up here
because I know Mark doesn't
agree but at this point we are you and I
are on the same page and and as
representative cabal um Illustrated
there are other things we need to work
on in future legislation but as far as
this goes right now we're just asking
simply for direct pay for payments that
are already being made perfect all
right you would can see me thank you and
we still get the ability to balance bill
for the rest correct they absolutely
have the balance bill in L and we don't
want to say that that insurance
companies can't pay for it if they do
want to pay for it that's out of the
generosity of their own heart but that
that's not what we're looking for in
this particular legislation so if the
insurance companies sending one check
with with their name to the patient why
don't we just whether it's the full
amount or whatever direct pay whatever
you want to call it why isn't it coming
to us I my guess is that this check was
the full amount I mean I I don't know
maybe maybe it wasn't but I guess this
check was probably the full amount but
at any rate if we can agree on what we
need to legislate on then then we're
we're golden so now I'd like to have the
insurance department
[Laughter]
thank you
Mark we can have this conversation again
offline
okay yeah you might want to press the
button and introduce yourself not that
almost everybody must know who you are
now I'm here often enough uh good
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee DJ beton Court commissioner of
the the New Hampshire insurance
department joined this morning by my
colleague Michelle Heaton who is the
head legal beagle of our life and health
unit wanted to just take a step back for
a moment and provide a little bit of an
update on an exercise that we went
through as a department this summer in
Fall of which this particular piece of
legislation was part of that that
discussion so as you know a Prohibition
against balance billing has been a
position the insurance department has
held for quite a long time uh we see it
from a consumer protection uh
perspective and and we think that what
happens to patients in these situations
is is quite
unfortunate but I've been coming to this
committee making that argument and
haven't gotten anywhere and neither had
any of my predecessors so it wasn't
anything exclusive to to
me but this summer I then saw a story in
the newspaper regarding uh some
commercial ambulance providers who were
going through major Financial struggles
and I thought to myself maybe this is
the opportunity for us to bring all of
the stakeholders together and see if we
can't come up with a solution that
solves this issue from the perspective
of the consumer from the perspective of
the provider and the perspective of the
carrier and so out of that came what I
dubbed the ambulance Summit and as I
said we met for a good portion of the
summer in Fall we brought all of the
stakeholders together and we learned a
lot uh we learned a lot it was a good
exercise although unfortunately we did
not ultimately reach an agreement on
what the best solution was but we did
throw out some proposals we put out some
potential Solutions it was part of a
package of
ideas one of those ideas Believe It or
Not Mr chairman don't fall off your
chair we suggested that perhaps a fee
schedule was appropriate uh Mr
Conservative here advocating for a fee
schedule but the reality is the two
sides are not negotiating and you're OB
you're obviously hearing differing
perspectives as to why that negotiation
is not taking place so we said well
let's do a fee schedule as a percentage
of Medicaid Medicare Medicare excuse me
do a Prohibition on balance billing and
address this direct pay issue so that
was one
idea that did not get agreement so he
said all right well we can do a minimum
allowed Mount so set that floor for
Rural and super rural which is where the
providers particularly in the commercial
space are really having trouble and
again we'll do the prohibition on
balance billing and prohibition on
direct pay that didn't go anywhere so we
then suggested an IDR process with that
floor again with the prohibition on
balance billing and the direct pay issue
the problem at the end of the day was
there is a fissure in the interests
between the commercial providers and the
municipal providers in each and every
one of those solutions that I U just
presented to you the providers would
have gotten additional funding would
have gotten more funding was it
everything they wanted no it was not
everything they wanted and I will say to
the carrier's credit each and every time
we've put one of these Solutions on the
table none of them ran out of the room
they were all willing to negotiate they
weren't in love with it uh but I don't
think that they particularly like the
status quo either so unfortunately as I
said we weren't able to come up with a
solution that was universally embraced
but what I will say is that the federal
government is coming uh they have not
forgotten that there is this Gap in the
no surprises act with ground ambulance
and I don't know what their solution to
this is going to be but I think in the
New Hampshire tradition we would much
prefer to have our own solution that is
attentive to the needs of of this state
rather than having the federal
government impose whatever it is that
they're going to bring forward on this
uh so that that's a little bit of the
context and the history that I wanted to
provide to you I will say I have a great
deal of concern for the commercial
ambulance
providers that's not to say that I don't
have concern for the municipal providers
but the municipal providers at the end
of the day have a back
stop you and I uh and and the fire
budgets that our communities ultimately
pass and ultimately we as property
taxpayers pay for the commercial
providers do not and those are the
entities that I'm very concerned about
um and as I said it was unfortunate we
couldn't get to an agreement but there
are solutions out there and I think that
as you approach this you want to do so
in a comprehensive way um so those are
my thoughts Michelle anything to add um
just with respect to direct pay that is
kind of one of of the bargaining chips
so if you allow them to get direct pay
now there's less of an incentive for
them to come to the table and negotiate
negotiate out these remaining issues and
at the end of the day it's still
allowing balance billing so when we hear
all of these stories I think probably
everyone in this room has heard a story
about someone getting build you know 10
$15,000 when all the ambulance head was
taken from um one facility to another
down the street or was an emergency call
right down the street
those stories are what's impacting
consumers and when we're talking about
consumers we're talking about like
representative hunt said those that are
purchasing commercial insurance in the
individual and small group markets
primarily there are some large group but
most large group is self-insured and
outside of our jurisdiction and this
bill is not going to fix that for them
they're still going to get that bill for
that
outstanding $9,000
$8,000 that the consumer is legally
liable for
so as representative hunt phrased it out
of the goodness of their hearts if the
insurer decides to cut a check to the
consumer that's great but they're not
legally obligated to do that and until
we come up with a solution that
prohibited balance billing in some way
it may not address everything and it's
going to be a work in progress but the
first step in the right direction is
prohibit balance
billing and I would just say to that too
as representative hunt of highlighted
the New Hampshire insurance department
only regulates approximately
30% of the health insurance Market in
New Hampshire the rest of it are the
government programs Medicare Medicaid
and then the the self-funded um plans
are obviously outside of our
jurisdiction as well um what I will say
is I firmly believe that the status quo
is unsustainable for the providers and
for
consumers I'm happy to continue the
conversation with all of the parties and
stakeholders to try to figure out what
the solution is uh but I will say that
even if you pass this bill it isn't the
it is not the fundamental
reform that this system
needs great so the question I have is do
you have a copy of the
bill so if if we interpret this bill is
that it's not about balance it's not
about the uh the the balance billing
billing or receiving or check writing it
is simply because it says subject to the
terms and conditions of the policy
plan that we should just go ahead and
pass this bill which just removes the
the check payment still will go to the
ambulance company but that check that's
going to go through to them is based
upon whether they're in network or out
of network and what the insurance
company was re reimbursing based on some
those conditions so if they're in
network it's already going directly to
the provider if they're out of network
and you pass this bill that means the
allowed amount the amount that the the
insurer says is commercially reasonable
for the rates being right for what's
being charged that check would go
directly to the provider corre and then
the balance billing check would go back
to the consumer if they so generously do
that yes but doing that makes it
provides less incentive for the
providers to come in network because now
they don't have to get that direct pck
but the check is going to be smaller yes
significantly small and then they've got
to struggle to go get that balance
payment yes so there is it's not I mean
you could say there is some disadvantage
but you know there's there's a little
play in there that might make it work
and uh so I I I guess at this point I
would be willing just to pass this as
written unless someone can shly tell me
this is a bad
idea
yeah thank you thank you so this is just
for a small segment as we discussed so
the rest of the um percentages of the
different tiers of insurance if the what
happens to that quote balance
Bill the consumer will still get the
bill from the provider and still be
liable for paying that out standing
amount so just to give some perspective
we use um Medicare rates kind of as a
basemark in a lot of um Health cost
stuff so right now um and it really
depends on the code and whether you're
rural super rural urban so there's a lot
of varying factors but most allowed
amounts are around you know 120 to 150%
of Medicare what's being build sometimes
is over 700% of Medicare so that larger
amount is what the consumer is still
going to be liable for so if the
consumer takes the Check Cashes it and
then doesn't pay the provider the
provider is the one that needs to go
after the consumer and that's where this
problem is because the providers either
don't have the bandwidth to do it or
they don't want to because it's you know
their neighbor or something this doesn't
change that problem at all and that's
the majority of the money we're talking
about okay representative
Burrows sorry
okay so um I guess my question is um so
there the commission met over the summer
and in the fall and so we still know
have so we do not have a consensus so is
your feeling that we still should not
pass this bill to give relief and wait
till waiting for gdau I guess to to fix
it does it he doesn't okay gdau never
showed up no I didn't realize look
whether or not to move forward with this
legislation is a policy call that's
that's for you to make if you're asking
my opinion I think in order to address
the issue as a whole you're going to
want to move forward with something a
little bit more comprehensive of which
this would be an integral
part followup I I just I I this is a
would you believe um is would you
believe that it's going to be a very
long time before we have a
comprehensive um plan and I don't see a
problem with if there's in this case the
ambulance provided are really hurting
could go out of business I don't see a
problem with addressing a piece of that
until we have the comprehensive plan
well I would just say I I don't know
that I would completely agree with that
because as I said before you do have the
fact that the federal government is is
working on a proposal right now to deal
with balance billing on ground ambulance
Senate Apprentice is very involved with
that effort uh their proposal is
currently uh proprietary but at some
point it is going to come forward I
don't know what that will look like as I
said before I
think we want to have a New Hampshire
solution rather than than a a solution
imposed Upon Us by the federal
government that may or may not
work and and look as I said before you
know the proposals that we put forward
didn't get consensus but at the end of
the day it all all of them provided the
ambulance providers with additional
financial
support so that was forward progress the
problem that we seem to run into was
that for one provider or another it
wasn't enough it wasn't uh sufficient to
cover all of their
costs well my view of it was well let's
let's make some progress on this let's
get you some more support and we can
keep working on this in the future but
that unfortunately fell
apart well that some people might say
that we're we're putting off by passing
this bill we're putting off the the uh
the incentive to get the issue solved
coming uh well I I would also add though
that some providers do do I'm not
providers sorry carriers are directly
paying already so they have the option
to direct pay or to pay the consumer and
not everyone is paying the consumer so I
think overall they're not going to see
much I mean I'm speculating here but I
don't think they're going to see the
relief they're expecting by this bill
passing yes
representative so this bill will not do
any harm it might move the ball forward
incrementally but what will it we all
see it as an issue but what will it take
to get the conversations going again and
making sure that we could keep making
progress no no is not an answer I think
the big sticking point point that we're
at is this philosophical divide as to
the underlying issue of Commercial
Insurance can't cover the full cost of
providing emergency services so who's
going to make up that Gap do you want to
raise rates on Commercial insurers to
bridge that Gap and doing so could cause
upward pressure on insurance premiums
and the people paying those are people
in the individual and small group
markets predominantly or or is it up to
the taxpayers to bridge that Gap and I
think that's the fundamental divide if
we had a decision as to who should be
paying that then we have a way forward
but right now it's all over the place
some people think balance spilling is
great and that the consumer who uses the
services should have to pick up the um
that Gap in money others feel that it's
the commercial insurers who should be
picking up that Tab and bridging that
Gap and then others feel that it's the
communities the communities decide what
is um appropriate emergency services and
how much they want to spend on funding
that and they're the ones that should be
Bridging the Gap so that fundamental
issue right there is what causes us to
not get consensus on any of these um
smaller pieces if we had some direction
that way then I think it'd be easier for
everyone to come to the table and we say
the legislature has said this is how it
should be funded so let's work on that
aspect but I don't know how you go about
doing that other than a finding in my in
my perspective the problem is
Medicare Medicare is the Lion Share of
ambulances and Medicare is the one
that's not paying enough and even if we
were to just say okay we're going to
make our base the individual insurance
uh equal to what Medicare well they're
already greater so yeah it's Medicare is
where where the money needs to come from
and yes that's federal government and
yes they they did it for everybody they
did balance billing for everybody
including ambul I mean helicopters but
they didn't do it for the ground
ambulance so okay thank you very
much uh how does everybody want to think
about this before we take any action or
or people want to just run run with this
amendment the bill as it as it's written
or should we make sure it really says
what we think it's supposed to say and
so you want to take sub take a sub
committee or should we wait no take it
okay no excuse me no Amendment this is
the bill we're going to vote the bill as
is as
is okay anybody have any reason why we
should not vote this bill as is speak
now for everyore hold your
pce okay uh so who do we
have
Terry that's matching okay all right so
it's uh hunt MCU belli Burrows and
collabro okay all those in favor of I'll
make a motion of ought to
pass
second okay all those in favor of a to
pass raise your
hand three
four six so it' be six who's not
[Music]
voting one two
wait minute you only have one two three
four five six seven names who's missing
in that list five here okay all right
anyway we got we got a vote we got a
five votes that's we're good
enough five zip
I well we but you said but Gibbs is not
here Gibbs isn't here and Terry so
that's so seven and Terry's not here
right okay and who was the other person
oh Vincent okay so we missing a Democrat
okay we're fine no we don't we're all
set we got five set
okay all
right 5
Z
okay uh okay um 1296
so we're waiting for a fiscal note on
12 is that what we waiting for the a
fiscal note on
1296 yes hi Michelle heaten New
Hampshire insurance department um we did
submit the fiscal note to OS last week
but I'm sure they just haven't gotten
around to they haven't got around
finalizing it and getting it out so I do
have a copy of it here if you like
so as those are going around I can kind
of summarize things a little bit for you
um there will be some impact but at this
point it's in determinable we don't know
how much we think it would be relatively
low part of the problem with this is
that is with respect to cost sharing
there's a lot of variables when you're
trying to predict cost sharing because
it depends on the individual's plan and
we don't know who's going to need these
services and what types of plans they're
in if they have a platinum plan their
cost sharing is a lot lower than someone
with a bronze plan so it's very hard to
estimate the impact here um but we did
do some uh we looked at some chis data
for these types of services and overall
most of these are provided with um
little to no cost sharing um and I
believe let me jump
it so the mean cost of um cost sharing
for these Services was nonzero but
trivial across the three most commonly
buil diagnostic mamography
services um and those are the codes
there um we had 34,000 codes which is a
lot lower than all of the mammograms um
being
conducted for commercial insurers and
manag Care organizations the median cost
sharing was zero so that means that most
of them have no cost sharing um but for
some diagnosis we observed a non-m
median cost value of less than $100 so
the cost sharing was under um
$100 the median cost sharing for those
who had cost sharing was under
$100 and that's about uh 0 3% so overall
it's going to be a small impact but
again estimating cost sharing is very
hard to do especially too you have to
think of the out-of-pocket Max so if
someone has a $5,000 out-of-pocket Max
for their plan which is actually kind of
low if they've already spent that 5,000
then they don't have to pay any cost
sharing for this so depending on when
someone got the services if it's later
in the year and they already met their
cost sharing they may have nothing if
it's earlier in the year and they have
not messed their their um out-of pocket
max then they need may need to pay more
so that's why it's very difficult
there's a lot of different variables
here so it's very difficult difficult to
assess the cost of it so I'm happy to
answer any
questions okay well the bill
says no
deductible it says that it wouldn't be
part of it you can't apply cost sharing
to these Services exactly yes so if
someone had a
5,000 then that would mean that would
mean it would cost the insurance company
have to to they would have to pay the
full
amount well it would depend on your
outof pocket max for your plan and
whether you've already met it that's
with estimating the overall cost for
this but we see the um median of those
who pay out of um who have cost sharing
associated with it as being less than
$100 for these specific services but
that's very deductible you're talking
not necessarily it could be you know Co
Insurance co-pay um they haven't met
their out of pocket Max or maybe they
only have a small amount left to meet
their out of pocket max so there's a lot
of different variables that make it
difficult to estimate I guess I'm still
fuzzy let make sure I understand okay um
I have a
$5,000
deductible right and this is the only
thing we say not me my wife okay this is
the only thing my wife needs is this
thing and we see that it it costs like
$2,000 to operate this unit
okay that is not $100 that's
$2,000 that I have to pay the way I read
the bill and I'm trying to find my copy
of it is that that that 2,000 will get
waved yes if your plan says that for
these Services you have to meet your
deductible first if there's a co-pay or
C um co- Insurance associated with the
service you'd only have to pay the
co-pay or the co- Insurance until you
meet your deductible and out- of- pocket
that's the way the Bill's written yes so
it would it would wave any cost sharing
and it would depend on the plan design
to determine what that means for each
person and there's a lot of variability
in plan design that's why it's very hard
to estimate how the F uh fiscal impact
of this if it were to be enacted but
based on the claims data we're
estimating that it'll be relatively low
but there is an impact
on on the current claims data yes but on
the current claims data the the
deductible is being paid by the
patient yes if that's what the plan
designed so your plan could say that
right but we're more interested in what
happens if we pass this legislation
where it says the deductible is no
longer that that the patient doesn't
have to pay the deduc yes so how much is
that going to be and that's what's hard
to figure out because every plan
will charge a different amount so if it
goes to your deductible then yeah you
could be stuck paying that $2,000 and
this bill would fix that so you don't
have to pay anything for other people it
could be $50 co-pay for this service so
now they don't have to pay that $50
co-pay 50 is nominal right I'm I'm
focusing I'm focusing in on people who
have high deductible
plans yeah so then it would be a higher
impact for that and that 2,000 GRS and
and that and then so the guesstimate is
how many how many women on an annual
basis would have just saved the
$2,000 if we have P if we pass this bill
yeah and that's very hard to determine
because we don't know how many of that
would take way more analysis to figure
out okay what kind of plan the people
getting these Services have high
deductible health plans are usually for
younger people who are relatively
healthy these services
um can apply to anyone at any time in
life so it's very hard to estimate that
and it really is dependent on the type
of plan you have how much of an impact
this bill would have on okay
representative
spear thank you uh at the first meeting
we had on this subject uh we were given
information in in the typical way that I
have I of course verified all of it uh
there are quite a few states that
already have passed this kind of
legislation and we were given a stack of
analysis about that thick showing us
what the the type of analysis that went
into the cost increase for
Massachusetts and it was very very
detailed and it came down to 13 to 33
cents and it's been enacted it looks
like about 18
states it seems to me that the data does
exist for you to figure this out at
least at the level that Massachusetts
figured it out so I would think if you
need this I'd be glad to give you my
copy of it uh that there is a way to get
this information it shouldn't have been
that hard I would think because it it
already exists what we can do is and
this would be a much more detailed
analysis that would require a lot more
time and may need um an outside
consultant to help out with so that
would be different I was suspecting it
was a mandate analysis and usually in
States when they request that mandate
analysis it's um you know actuaries get
involved it's a lot more detailed but we
won't be able to estimate moving forward
with too much specificity because it
really depends on what type of plan the
person has Massachusetts is not always
analogous to New Hampshire because they
have mass health um and they have a lot
of different other programs their
Market's very different than in New
Hampshire so you can't use that
necessarily as a comparison what we did
is we looked at the last year of claims
data that we have for these diagnostic
codes what was the median cost sharing
and the median cost sharing is zero so
it could be that there's no cost sharing
because these people have already hit
their out-of-pocket Max so they're not
incurring any cost it could be that they
have plans that cover these without Co
Insurance there's a lot of different
variables that go into play so without
doing a deep dive into this data and
figuring out what kind of plan did these
people have why is there no cost sharing
for them and then why are um of the
people who did have cost sharing why is
it under a 100 the median for that um
some people definitely did pay more some
people paid less um but there's a lot of
variability here so we can look back at
our claims at it and try to figure this
out but even in Massachusetts seems like
they gave a range so we're saying that
this will cause an impact on premium
well not necessarily on premium is Will
insurers will have increased Health
costs and we think it's relative L low
increases but we can't give much more
specif specificity without doing a much
more detailed study right so yes I I
just had to follow on I based on what I
see the range of states are states like
Montana Colorado New Mexico Arkansas
Missouri Illinois Tennessee Georgia
between all of those States we can't
find a state that is similar to
ours no because a lot of those states
have lot larger populations the dynamics
of their Market I know monana does not
they're half our
population but um the market how many
players are in it what type of mandates
they already have in place all of these
things factor in and you would need a
much more in-depth study to figure that
out which we could do um we have the
ability to do that as a mandate study
but those studies typically run us
between 22 and
$44,000 to complete that
study right now we've already talked
about this already uh I don't know if
you were here when we did
last week okay so that that the mandated
study um is something that's been on the
statute for 10 about 15 years and that
whenever we get these health insurance
mandates that we really don't know how
what what the impact is is that we have
um have uh done done the study in that
study you have you set up parameters
about what is that you you want to look
at and what we're thinking about um but
I in my mind the big issue is that how
how many how many Employers in the state
actually have a very high deductible
plant because that's really what drives
it is the employer who is buying the
policy for the employees if they have if
if the employers and and I and I guess
I'm guilty as an employer I I have a
high deductible plan for my employees um
and that and so in that my case it would
be different but I I I don't have a
woman on my has an employment so it's
not an issue okay so not withstanding
that the high deductible is that the
question is does New Hampshire have a
disproportionate amount of high
deductible
plants okay the other issue in my mind
is that you um you don't want adverse
selection we want people to choose the
plan that is right for them not because
whether the high deductible or not is
going to get covered for a certain
mandated coverage or not so that's
that's always been my loose loose end
when it comes to these high deductible
plans but in this case the the so that
we would be asking the the way you would
do it is we would interim study the bill
we would be asking the department to do
it an cost analysis and then come next
year come next January we would then
have that in hand and then make a
decision what is the best way to to go
forward with this this a procedural
question then uh my understanding was an
on an interim study bill in the second
year it's just going to die it isn't
going to go to any kind of a vote well
what happens is next year okay is that
every bill can come back
again coming back so somebody would
reintroduce the bill next year but in
that public hearing and that reintroduce
it would be that
analysis the problem I'm having is that
we have enough information and I did my
own little research in that way that I
have that there
are too many states that are doing this
to just keep putting it off and that
women are being impacted I I think that
there is enough data right now to say
that we can do this or not do this
okay representative burough thank you is
I'm just wondering if there's an
industry person who could speak to this
who um could tell us why this this is or
isn't a good idea industry being
um somebody who supports the
bill that well that they were here
before but yeah they're in the
background right well um yeah I guess
why don't you come on up
and you're a sponsor of the bill right
yeah so the question would be
is how many how how many tests could
this cause in other words um if it's if
it's a oneoff it's not a big deal if
it's you know we one of the issues we
had was we were discussing last week was
that there theoretically it was going to
go on for another four years it would be
the free
test yes I guess I would suggest two
points that I don't believe we need an
analysis at this point because it has
been done in other states it is an
expensive undertaking we already have
heard and understand that is a limited
cost we're looking at the particular
point I wanted to make is just to
reiterate this does not apply to pre
High deductible plans you would have to
pay your deductible before this bill
would but it does say it does apply
there's an exemption in there I I don't
I'm sorry I don't have the paper in
front of me I should brought up with me
but um well if the deductible is the
only issue I have the co-pay is the
co-pay is nothing so to take your
example if I understood you correctly as
the employer with your your employees
having a high deductible plan they would
have to pay their deductible before this
bill would have effect okay so where
where is that in the
Bill thank you no oh you know what's
weird you got the definitions before the
statute so maybe an ordering issue that
was a little bit confusing perhaps okay
no group he Insurance off grou thank you
yes
uh any cost sharing requirements yes so
line eight okay oh it said all right for
healthare cont that meets the definition
of a high deductible plan and set for
this requirement shall only apply to the
employees satisfying the minimum
deductible for the year except other
than the mamogram you know or I believe
is the next phrase but um okay the point
being that you have still have to meet
your deductible before okay all right
great thank you so now insurance
department does this what does does
Roman numeral 2 really say when I the
definition what's a what's the
definition of a High deductible plan do
we even have that in our
statute it's defined federally and I'd
have to look at it exactly what but
these are high deductible plans are
designed for younger people and um the
idea is you pay lower premiums because
you're relatively healthy and you're
risking that you're not going to have
much at a cost so that's why very high
dble I'm what's the sure EMP employers
and I'd have to look that up I'm not
sure if employers can buy High
deductible plans it's a special type of
plan it's not just a plan that you would
relatively speaking think have a high
deductible so you could have a plan that
has you know a $10,000 deductible in
theory that's not the same as a high
deductible plan High deductible plans
work differently and under federally
those are um there are certain
preventative Services that at the
federal level have to be covered without
cost sharing that applies to the high
deductible plans but for this bill um it
would not apply to those federally
defined High deductible plans was just a
separate type of plan right okay did you
you found it okay yeah so it says the
reference definition is 26 us code
section 223 right so it says for
calendar year two for calendar year 224
a quote high deductible plan unquote is
defined under 223 c2a as a health plan
an annual DED annual deductible that is
not less than 1,600 for self-only
coverage or 3200 for family coverage and
for which the annual outof pocket
expenses parentheses deductibles co-
payments and other amounts etc etc um
hang on be the rest of
it so that that's 1600 per individual
3200 so as an employer who has a $5,000
plan but not premiums Okay so uh for
which the annual outof pocket expenses
deductible Co payments and other amounts
but not premiums do not exceed $850 for
self only 16,100 for family 8,000 that
was no that's
um out of pocket minimum so that's not
the deductible that's the out of pocket
right so the there that's what I'm I'm
talking about is when it's talk our
famous eobs right explanation of
benefits Y and when we get those and
they're going to say you know how much
the insurance company's covering and how
much I have to cover but that that uh
that I have if I have a 5,000 deductible
that means I've got to pay I gotta I got
to pay that excess amount up until it
reaches the uh the the dollar the full
5,000 no no out a deductible and out of
pocket are different so deductible is
like you pay the first amount and then
the deductible is usually 50 100 bucks
nothing not nothing depends cop Co
excuse me excuse me cop right copay is
it it's the deductible that can be the
high high amount then there's the out of
pocket max which is the total so you may
need to meet your deductible and then Co
insurance will kick in until you meet
your out of pocket max so for high
deductible they're are they're a
separate type of plan um and they have
other requirements but the out of pocket
max I believe you said is
8,6 for the individual and
161 for family so that's but they
operate differently that includes
everything like even your 25 bucks at
CVS to pick up your prescription okay so
this is a very narrow little exemption
that we don't you need to have that to
comp so that the plans comply with
Federal requirements and IRS
requirements for that type of plan okay
uh I guess I'm I'm what I'm just trying
to get at is what what is available what
are people buying in New Hampshire and
when these but I think like I have a I
have a Harvard
plan for my employees and I guess I
guess I would ask you
Peter so even then I have what I call
the high deductible I had the I'm in the
you know the small group Market I'm
paying the high I'm paying the lowest
possible premium and I have the highest
possible
deductible that's not necessarily a high
deductible plan High deductible plans
work differently but Dr as is is here
and he did the um analysis of the chis
data and I believe correct me if I'm
wrong Jason but um when he was looking
at it it didn't look like anyone that
had these high deductible Health Plans
um had any of these services in the last
year so because they're usually more
younger more relatively healthy people
that are um buy those types of plans
because you're responsible for paying
most of your healthcare costs until you
meet that out of pocket max where the
more additional health insurance that
you're thinking of hmos ppos um the
insurer is paying parts of it until you
re your chair out of pocket max and then
they cover all of it so it's a little
bit different and that's why you would
have lower deductibles if you have
higher cost
sharings if you have higher deductibles
then you're usually going to have lower
cost
sharings
okay
okay so you're think this is not going
to cost
much
relatively
small may I just add the postcript for
what we our hearing will be relatively
small impact an $80 charge for a patient
who's not going to have followup is
going to have huge ramifications and we
have heard testimony that effect I think
you got some emails this week um so what
is a small cost perhaps or limited cost
overall to insures is a huge impact on
patients and all of us down the road
okay get off my soap box now all right
great so um thank you thank you very
much so Heidi uh and Sabrina you guys
want to tell us if you know anything
different in terms of what this analysis
is and that this is not going to have a
big huge impact on insurance
premium
Heidi good morning Mr chairman um
members of the committee Heidi croll
Gallagher Callahan and gartell on behalf
of ahip so I don't have anything to add
to I don't have any insights into the
cost impact I would say that um on the
high deductible Health lands I know
there's also an um the health savings
account has a piece to that I thought in
terms of IRS that um that
the if you violate the definition of a
high deductible health plan then the tax
advantage of the health savings account
is put into Jeopardy and you potentially
have the patient is left with a
liability
so I don't I don't know how that all
fits into what you just heard but it's
just another for example I know where I
work we have a high deductible health
plan with a health savings account tied
to it so so you might be you might be
your employ so might be impacted by this
USC section
223c right right that that part and then
the other thing I guess I would just say
um with respect to the you know any sort
of um in the current situation um where
people have bills with providers um to
the best of my knowledge most providers
will um work with people to have payment
plans so I just wanted to put that into
the the people if if in the example that
was given that you know paying $80 out
of pocket at that particular moment is
not feasible um to my understanding most
providers are very willing to to come up
with payment plans so right right which
would help spread it out at least so you
not all at that that's just the uh the
copay copay yeah okay thank you all
right okay um because
yeah because I know we have then the
other one was the the diabetes the
monitoring devices for the diabetes but
I think that one we were talking about
going into to doing the study to find
out what what that was that one we
talked about we need to do the study so
um okay so if people want to pass this
bill thinking that it's not going to
cost much page
two okay so uh representative Burrows
seconded by representative hunt moves
ought to
pass
any discussion on the
motion say none all all those who favor
say I one two three three four five
right it this Mo 5
Z
okay five Z
okay all right moving right along next
up is
12:25 conflict of
interests so I understanding is that
there was a conflict of interest did
already come up with this board and that
person did resign anybody here involved
in this
issue nobody in this
room that you can confirm that did
happen so at this point I'm not sure
this really a problem here um but I
guess we could hold have do an interim
study so that in case a problem does
come up we can then do something in the
future is everybody comfortable with
doing an inter room
study all
right yeah the amendment was insane
sorry
so the recommendation is interim
study
so then the next one the
glucose um so I I think you did send me
a what we what we should be asking for
for a glucose
study
yes I sent you an email outlining kind
of um how the studies work um as I
mentioned before usually we uh consult
with outside experts on this and some of
these studies can range between 22,000
44,000 uh I we also outlined how we
believe the study should progress so
that you have the best information on
how to uh attack this issue and I have
Dr AIS here who can talk about how that
would be
designed so do you have yeah so normally
with some of these mandate mandate
studies or quasi mandate studies we try
to do a few things which I talked to
Michelle to find out what does this bill
aim to do that's usually with regards to
expansion of the eligible population and
or expansion of the covered benefits in
any cost sharing implication so we
usually look at that in in terms of
different domains the size of of the the
new population the size of the new
benefit and any other economic
implications for the different
parameters of cost sharing so we we say
cost sharing we're talking about
deductible co-pay and co- Insurance
collectively and so that's generally the
the analytic framework that we use to do
a claims analysis for any purpose
including the fiscal note
worksheets okay any questions from
committee members so so just to um
obviously we have type one and type two
and then we have the you know g g
something gdm right which is what what
is gestational diet gestational yeah I I
see that sounds like pre pregnancy to me
but it is shows you
it and um H hypoglycemia I believe is
also a subclinical diagnosis included in
this legislative language yeah okay so
um and and then in terms of the
pregnancy one that just says is that is
that after a important time then they
won't need it anymore or yeah it's not
so it's really we're just covering while
they're while they're pregnant to make
sure that they're monitoring often times
the 12 weeks subsequent delivery okay so
it's just it's just call it a
year okay um all right so yeah this
mandate report if you asked us to do we
would look at each one of these eligible
populations and what that would mean for
um providing these services in the
increase in and premium we'd also be
looking at the utility and medical
efficacy of whether these populations
can benefit from having these devices
available good any other questions from
committee
members okay um so I would move uh
interim
study yes public hearing you would ask
me to get some information I don't know
if you oh great what what did you get
for me get for
us I think one of the thank you Mr chair
Peter bragon representing Harvard
Pilgrim Healthcare as you may know the
state's only non-for-profit health
insurance company and you asked me to to
get a couple of things but one of the
issues was and I think it was
representative Terry may have asked but
we were told that this uh this same
legislation appears in numerous other
States including Rhode Island you may
recall that and representar ask me don't
you guys cover Rhode Island so uh can
you tell us what your experience has
been because this certainly can't cost a
lot of money if Rhode Island is doing it
so it turns out the Rhode Island bill um
is nothing similar to this bill uh it
requires coverage for glucose monitoring
devices subject to all prior
authorization and cost sharing
limitations of existing policies on
existing this bill removes all prior
authorization and all cost share uh what
we have now is what the Rhode Island
Bill mandates that they cover it we
already cover it uh the issue we have
with this bill is this bill takes away
prior authorization and takes away any
um cost sharing uh which I think as the
department does its cost study uh make
sure that's included because without the
prior authorization then these and the
testimony was that conses glucose
monitoring systems cost $500 per month
uh and there's 100,000 uh diabetics in
New Hampshire so you do the math out and
you're talking $600 million of expenses
so uh so the key Ben the key as I was
asked to find is uh this is nothing like
the Rhode Island law right because of
that those limitations we just had in
the previous Bill correct um I was also
asked what uh the medical guidelines
were for Harvard for continuous glucose
monitoring I can send that to you all
it's uh probably eight pages um but then
the process the other question I was
asked is what are the process for
determining medical necessity guidelines
and at least within Harvard there's a uh
panel of medical directors all of our
medical directors of the different uh
branches uh get together there's also
members of staff for legal staff for
instance and things like that um only
the medical directors have a vote but
the other staff can um provide input um
and then they rely on subcommittees and
there's a subcommittee for every
individual practice so in this case
there's a uh a advisory committee or
advisory sub it's not even a
subcommittee it's made up the the appr
policy approval committee is all Harvard
Pilgrim employees licensed uh medical
directors who are employed their
fulltime job is to study everything
that's going on then they rely on
advisory committees made up of
practicing Physicians who are in network
uh and they meet they have to meet at
least annually or more often if new
technologies come in that that may
require uh some more look um and so we
have a a provider Advisory Group on
endocr
Endocrinology which is the study of the
the hormonal system production of
production of insulin Etc they make
recommendations to the policy approval
committee um and again only the doctors
on that committee actually have a vote
as to what happens so the legal people
can advise them about all that's going
on but the doctors are the ones that
vote on it so that's kind of a
background they I wanted to put
something in writing and they said well
we'll have to have our legal department
review that I said okay we don't have
six months to wait for that so that's
kind of the overall background so we
just have tell everybody to watch this
YouTube yeah I did I said you know I'm
going to say it it's it's on YouTube so
um that's that that's my understanding
of it as an overview so I will send a
the uh the document on so you're saying
that the Rhode Island law implemented
something that's everybody was already
doing yeah mandates coverage of the
things we already cover uh what this
bill does it it says you have to cover
all these things oh by the way there's
no prior approval requirement so that so
this bill does go further than that in
terms it gu gets rid of all the mandates
and all right and again it's the cost
thing that that's cost going to come
somewhere it's going to come from
premiums and uh at some point people
can't afford the concerns they have
themselves okay so why did they passed
the bill if everybody was doing it
already you know sometimes as a former
legislator I recall all things coming up
and it uh it seems like the right thing
to do or maybe you don't know it's
already being done so or maybe you don't
believe it's already being done so okay
or maybe it's really old and people
weren't doing it back then maybe could
be we you don't you don't know how old
the statue is on island I don't but I
can find out figure figure out whether
that because does seem a little weird
but okay any uh anybody have any yeah uh
oh turn your mic on Chris turn your mic
on now I've done
it so the the the the uh restraint on
having $600 million go out the door is
prior approval is is that the is that
the basic restraint no the cost of the
equipment well the the cost you say you
can't have it then you don't have to pay
for it yeah PRI and our prior
authorization I I'll I'll well you know
I got a few copies I'll just pass it
around PRI authorization
yeah yeah which I'm sure similar to
ours and and I'm sure they have external
grievance too uh yes and so a good thing
to remind you is that uh if a prior
authorization is denied um because uh
the provider feels that the particular
situation is different in some way then
there's an appeal process that goes
through both the uh both Harvard program
as well as through the insurance
department I believe if that's not
satisfactory so in this particular one
is a little confusing because it covers
a bunch of different plans and different
different states but uh the main piece
is probably uh the the critical piece
for New Hampshire is on halfway down the
second page um and it just lists out the
criteria to use for continuous glucose
monitoring so um you know number one it
has to be prescribed by a professional
provider in order to be considered
medically necessary uh if it's medically
necessary it's approved automatically so
in order to be continued medically
necessary it has to number one be
prescribed by a professional provider
with expertise in treating diabetes
secondly the the member has to be on a
treatment program already and again if
the cost of um the monitoring strips is
$20 a month and the cost of a continu
gluc continuous glucose monitoring
system is $500 a month we're going to
want to they're likely going to want to
start with the least expensive options
to see if they work but at some point
they don't work and I think there's a
line in here that says that just at
times the self um what's it called the
self- administration self-monitoring
doesn't work and so other things are
necessary so these things are put
together by the U medical guideline
committee with the advice of in this
case the
endocrinologist uh advisory committee uh
to apply so um well it's great it's
always good to look under the uh under
the under the hood under the hood here
how the medical directors operate be
careful when um people testify and say
oh they're doing it in this state
they're doing it that state or seven
other states are doing this uh they're
all doing something different so in this
case the island is not the variation
yeah
good yes
repres thank Mr
chairman could you comment on um the
professional shortterm CGM so you've got
it at 7 to 14 days uh the only thing I
know about that is that so there's two
types there's one a professional
short-term where the provider wants to
get an idea of what's Happening uh
versus a long-term thing to actually
help the member uh manage their system
and so the I think the short-term one is
covered uh no matter what um to allow
the provider to have the data they need
to make a decision for like for gational
that that's what I'm wondering is if we
expanded that 7 to 14 to a little longer
in the case of gational diabetes which
uh there may be a separate uh piece in
here for gational diabetes too I'm not
sure it's beyond my expertise I was
asked to get a copy of it so I've
exhausted my knowledge of
yeah okay thank you Peter okay um make a
motion seconded by representative bur to
inter room
study and do the mandated study mandated
cost
analysis as outlined yes as
outlined okay and any discussion on the
motion you want you want to make it or
you want me to make
it yeah I I'm making the motion just to
move move things
along any discussion on the motion of in
room study seeing none all those in
favor raise your
hand one two three four five
okay
great all right
uh let's go into life Insurance relative
insurance coverage for living organ
donors how do we leave this
bill
[Music]
can this will this will simply prohibit
insurance carriers life insurance
carriers from denying you sarily if
you've chosen to give a kidney to your
brother or sister or or you know tissue
donor or I mean or the other criteria
set forth
here insurance companies actually do
this do that yeah anybody here sometimes
in certain cases insurance
department sh he in housein law legal
counsel yes
um so well we're talking about life
insurance yes there's a lot of things
that can be considered that you
typically would not be able to consider
underwriting fully permitted in in
Spades when it comes to so if there's
actu statistical information that
suggest that had if you're a living
donor you know your life expectancy
would go down that is one of the things
that they can consider um I think what
this is trying to do is making sure that
they can't deny or cancel
um or increase
premiums
so typically so this is life insurance
so life insurance you know you think
about it you know in the old days with
health insurance you know they would
actually do a physical they would you
know say we're not going to have any
pre-existing conditions okay and we
banned that with health insurance but
with life insurance said they're very
interested in pre-existing conditions
they're very interested in all those
things and yes the key thing is what
she's saying is is that the only if they
want to limit something or or you know
deny it they have to have uh proof the
case of case studies that shows that
there has to be actu act evidence St
statistical evidence to suggest that
this Factor could impact your life
expectancy right and it's one of the
factors so um where we say deny or
cancel coverage there's we wouldn't have
an issue with that because
what would likely happen is your premium
is going to go up um reducing or
limiting or making it so you can't
increase
premiums could be a problem for life
insurance I'm not going to speak on
their behalf but if you were to buy a
life insurance policy say when you're 30
relatively healthy your premiums are
usually depending on the type of policy
you know you you could probably expect
your premiums to go up as you age
because your risk of dying increases as
you get
older so if you have something that
comes up usually they don't underwrite
your health again
um but I guess if you were on some kind
of living donor list that you had and
they found out about it that would be a
mechanism for them to increase your
premium so that's kind of how this works
I'm not I wasn't here for the original
hearing so I don't know what the
testimony was about but um I I'm pretty
sure I was scheduling bills so I was out
of the room at the time but so but a lot
I think a lot of the other um laws we
see in other states are prohibiting
unfair discrimination but that would not
prohibit the insurer from considering
this in
underwriting right they just can't use
it as a sole basis for denying you
coverage it just be one of the many
factors that can who is encouraging
people to to donate or to consider
donating be and people are afraid to
donate sometimes because they think
they're not going to be get life
insurance and therefore protect the rest
of their family they they need to look
at their life insurance plan before they
they they decide
or they just might be thinking if
they're in their 30s they might be
thinking well geez I'm at 50 I want life
insurance I've got three kids or
whatever and if I go give this donation
now I may not be able to get it
later right so the sponsor I I was
looking at the sponsor and I see the
speaker of the house here cor I was
thinking transportation that that we
when we get our when we renew our
licenses they always ask whether you
want to become a donor an organ donor
that's deceased donor right as a
deceased owner so that right so this is
your your neighbor is life insurance
about
dying in other words could can't say can
they say we refuse to give you your your
life insurance Your settlement because
you you you no no this is a living donor
this is this is a living donor a living
donor okay so it's you know you're going
to be living with one kidney if you gave
a kidney to your right relative or a
stranger who and that would could
potentially affect your longevity and
there's there's always a shortage of
morgage like we know that and and I'm a
little bit familiar with some of the
sponsors feelings on this so I won't
speak for him but I believe he was the
recipient actually I think he testified
to that yeah right or yeah or he's quite
quite familiar with it okay so the
department would be okay you're okay
with one tonight or we're okay with
whatever you guys want to
do the issue is in line 10 we want I
want one thing I'm acutely aware when we
now when we talk about life insurance
and Property and Casualty which is not
to confuse with health insurance is one
of the things we don't want to be an
outlier compared to other states because
then our premiums would be higher and we
would have less companies less
competition in the marketplace so we
don't want to be too crazy about how far
we go we want to be in the norm of what
other states are are doing I believe
there's about a handful I think maybe
like 10ish States who have passed laws
similar to this and they all um focus
around prohibiting unfair discrimination
against living donors and just to be
clear these are people who have actually
donated and are still alive not someone
who's contemplating donation oh okay and
it affects both though I think it
affects the size of the likely donor
pool if it's on if it comes to your mind
that you may impact your ability to be
covered in the future and and therefore
you know provide that coverage to your
family yeah the so but underwriting is
is
reasonable yeah so in the public hearing
got John Hoffman who is he he said he
says n n NCO NCO enco does enco have a
policy on
this I am not sure but en coil is for
legislators promoting policy and not
necessarily industry so I'm not sure how
about neic how about that would be I
have not seen anything from neic on this
nothing on the Nic yeah and that's
that's where we really want to be on
same page with because that that really
affects our premiums and our
competitiveness in our
Market well it sounds like we need we
need to learn more about this before we
get
crazy so how about interim study and so
we can learn learn more how about we
just take out increase the
premiums those three words in line
uh reduce or limit code so they can
still underwrite and and if between the
parties the donor and recipient
especially if it's
familial uh you know I think it's it's
possible to overcome that
underwriting but I'm not sure we can
prohibit underwriting I think there's
more to that sentence the reduce or
limit or um coverage or benefits or
increase usually it's a tradeoff if you
don't want your benit it's in or if you
don't want your premium increased then
you're going to have to agree to take a
lower amount of benefits so it would
it's a little bit different um but
again I don't know enough about it to to
say too much more beyond that but I
would say just taking out the increas in
premiums is not going to necessarily
well you take out the whole paragraph
you take the whole you take out the
whole paragraph and that's okay so let's
see where we leave uh preclude a covered
person from donating all or part of an
organ as a condition of receiving or
continue see coverage on
her so that's kidneys right because that
you you give
part
re okay so do we want to leave that in
there you get liver part of your liver
right they do
that
okay so
you how many lawyers do we have in the
room any other paragraph you would want
to remove what what anything
else I mean I again I don't I don't want
to be too off the reservation when it
comes to other states and passing this
legislation do you want more time to
yeah I mean if you want to think about
how we can Tinker with this I can take
it back and do a little bit more
research on it I know that what I'm not
seeing here which I did see in a lot of
the other ones was the phrase the unfair
discrimination so I'd want to see if
that's something that we want to put in
okay ah right so you want to use more
language that other states have used yes
so um I can take it back and look at
some other stat yeah we don't have to
take action on this yet so 19 States
according to quick quick research okay
but I would caveat that that it's not
the same bill in all 19 so be very
different in what has actually passed
but 19 have something and three have
pending okay we're going to
reschedule
and uh wait for the Department to come
up with a a standard standard language
for yes that would be more in line with
what the majority of States done very
important
okay is everybody okay with that yeah
all right great
okay relative to contracts between
Public Adjusters and the insured didn't
didn't I thought we were going to take
care
of then we we're going to dispose of
this who anybody here for this bill
where's
George what happened to Henry what
happened to all the lobbyists for this
bill the insurance department recommends
itl to enable further review yeah okay
yeah that's what we want
okay I can confirm that all right
anybody want to make that motion okay
pelli okay representative Peli second
representative hunt Moves In in expedent
to legislate in 1257 any discussion on
the motion scene none the clerk well
excuse me all those in favor please say
I two three four five
okay and last but not least
all right um are we okay with this
amendment did you did I gave I know I
gave it
to right did did you get a get a copy of
this
amendment yes we did receive a copy of
the amendment uh my my name is Keith and
I have the Deputy Commissioner at the
insurance department um happy to answer
any questions you have uh
I I think we're I think we all get it
it's pretty clear just you know we don't
we don't need to
have glass the glass man who comes into
I always love it the fact that they
drive to your house and put that glass
in right
there to me I love that so but to make
them an insurance adjuster would be
insane
yes okay so but everything else in the
bill is correct is that right nobody got
the that is correct representative yeah
everything else is well this is only the
subcommittee members need to get it so
right not everybody needs it yeah here
I'm sending it over it's because these
two are hogging the amendment when they
don't need to you can just read it
you're not on the subcommittee just it
needs to get to the
members
okay you would just always always
suspicious of what's going on right
[Laughter]
okay
okay uh anybody want to make the
motion vot to pass on this
amendment okay I
will all right I move V to pass on the
amendment any
discussion a second uh sure
representative
seconds all those in favor say I 1 two 3
four five okay U Move ought to pass as
amended any discussion on the
motion see none all those in favor say I
three four five
okay all right so the only one we need
to come back for is the living organ
donors and we'll get that
standardized okay we're all
done this just for my
records